yeah i think look things happen and i
think what happens kev is people don't
focus on all the positive i mean i had
uh five years of of an incredible
life in in partnership as far as
life goals and business goals i just
hope that i continue to evolve
i'm continuing
seven eight years in therapy uh i always
say to people i'm a work in progress
how many jobs you have now
really how many jobs do i have
i don't know they're all like little
part-time jobs
but you know kevin i'm at a point in my
life that i'm actually doing all the
things that i love to do
and i'm probably not going narrow and
deep in anything
but i'm actually kind of
white and shallow but doing all the
things that i really like to do and not
be overwhelmed by them el presidente is
really all about mastering what you do
you master baseball
now you've mastered business
what is that like what is that like to
rise to the top in two different things
you know when i think about presidente
or i think about rising and anything i
think about like my childhood hero magic
johnson right i mean magic showed me
that you can be a hall of fame
basketball player in the in the hardwood
and then he could be a hall of fame guy
in the in the boardroom yeah and because
he was a man of color i looked at him
and said oh man why not me
and hopefully presidential with our
campaign to
endorse and promote young entrepreneurs
to be their presidente and go out why
not them right and i'm really excited
about this campaign we're doing and
hopefully i can open the doors for other
people of color minorities latinos women
and it's the right time for that tell me
about some of the folks that are in this
because i've seen the campaign and you
are championing folks who you know in
everyday life you might walk by and say
oh well yeah you're cutting hair but or
you're doing this but they are the best
in the business they are and as a young
artist out of bronx jordan is one of my
favorite examples i met jordan the
barber uh when he was just a young lad
in and he had nothing and all of a
sudden he's doing the yankees and he's
doing the mets and then he's doing all
the leagues are coming through and
they're getting their haircut by jordan
and by year five or six he started
buying little houses in dominican and
then buildings and him and his father
started a construction company
that's the perfect story and that's what
we're trying to accomplish with
presidente anybody can be presidente
anybody can be president absolutely
everybody should be this is the age this
is the golden age for entrepreneurship
and there's so much opportunity out
there that if you can get up and hustle
whether it's a high side hustle or your
main hustle
anybody can make it look if a young kid
like me made it from miami
because of baseball and i was able to
take that and do other things it also
gives me a platform to do great things
like this and help out you know the next
generation of entrepreneurs it's more
than just a drink it's about helping the
next level you had an epic birthday
it was a long one a long one how how was
it i had a business trip out out there
in europe and then i said you know what
talked to my homies i talked to my
family and said why don't you guys just
meet me out there and let's just go have
some fun we rented out a boat and then
we went down to a beason and the fact
that we get to rent that and share with
my family and my friends
so grateful to have my 46th birthday my
god kev we're getting old man
it was great how are the girls doing
because we last time i saw them was at
the super bowl when um your daughter
tried to take my job
how are they doing you know natasha and
i are doing fantastic uh natasha's a
rising junior elle is a rising eighth
grader school starts here in the next
few weeks
and we have a routine kev we we go to
work out then we have dinner
and then we lay in bed and we watch
outer banks
now i didn't think i was going to like
it but i'm all into it now and there's
so many banks yeah we're out of banks
yeah they have crushes on every kid
there and i just keep telling them well
their hair's too long and why they
shouldn't like them right
you just gave a speech at alabama which
was pretty cool and you talked to them
about
not losing the intensity that you know
you can be on the top of the world the
next day you can lose and what has that
been like for you and how do you apply
that to everyday business and also with
presidente look i mean with me i was at
the top of the world world champion and
then i had you know a one-year
suspension
and for me while it was the toughest
part of my professional career
it was probably the thing i'm going to
look back and say i am most thankful for
that because it allowed me to get back
and
really think about how i wanted my life
to move forward
and it's a lesson that i share with my
daughters is a lesson that i share with
young entrepreneurs you can be here but
tomorrow you can be down here yeah you
know it's funny you're talking about
being being able to move forward you in
the last year you've faced adversity and
you've continued to move forward is that
how you've applied to all the things
that have happened in the last year yeah
i think look things happen and i think
what happens kev is people don't focus
on all the positive like whatever's
happened to me over the last year i'm so
grateful for it i mean i had uh five
years of of an incredible
life and and partnership and also with
my daughters
we learned so much and now we have an
opportunity to take that and move
forward and say you know what we're so
grateful for the last five years how do
we make the next five years better
because of lessons learned so i'm in a
great place i'm so grateful for where
god in in
in in the light has really put me in and
uh i'm really looking forward
mostly to see how my girls keep
developing you are on cnbc almost as
much as you're online shark takes him
you see all these different things as
much as you are doing baseball
are you enjoying the business world more
i mean just like you i mean you've been
at it i've known you for 25 years and
i've seen you kind of come up and do
your thing i've done the same thing and
kept for me ever since i was 10 years
old it was about the two b's it was
baseball and business
and for whatever reason i mean my former
athletes they think i'm nuts they're
like dude you should be on that boat 52
weeks ahead of the year right right but
for me my what i love most is baseball
business and my my babies my girls right
the three b's all right so
how does it feel
to be the first ever latino mba owner
it's wild when they told me that i
couldn't believe it um
the truth is like
it's just like magic open doors for me
yeah hopefully i get to open doors for
millions of latinos and men of color and
women and it's my job as i enter the
boardroom to keep that door open for
others to come in it's not enough for me
to just come in and stay in that's
that's not enough minnesota is a cool
spot
and the interesting part is you know you
think about like the jerry jones is the
robert craft yeah before they were there
it wasn't like the cool place to be no
they made a cool you saw what uh dr bus
did with the lakers 100
so
is the baseball player always with you
yeah at heart i'm always a baseball
player i mean it's in my blood right but
kevin a lot of times i forget
most days that i ever played baseball
and i'm so focused on like what's next
right right i don't look back too much i
learn my lessons and then i move forward
and isn't that kind of a mentality that
a baseball player has to say you strike
out
you still you step up to the point short
memory man short
short there's always a lesson in
parenting and business and baseball but
it's so important to move forward
and i think that's been kind of my
competitive advantage the short memory
to take the lesson but move forward
all right let's um let's grab our beer
and we're gonna i'm gonna hit you with
rapid fire questions
you can sip
or you can answer who's the bigger
baller you're derek jeter bigger baller
me or derek jeter i think we're both
champions i think uh
we're both ballers
one
okay
idea of the perfect date night i would
say uh early so i'm an early person so
early dinner
uh
three four courses
nice cocktail glass of wine she'll
probably drink wine and probably drink
tequila
next goal
i think my number one goal in life is to
raise
two beautiful girls with high
self-esteem and to be a present father
there's nothing going to compare to that
as far as
life goals and business goals i just
hope that i continue to evolve
i'm continuing
seven eight years in therapy
i always say to people i'm a work in
progress biggest regret
you know it's funny um when it comes to
regrets
i i just think that
there's things that i look back kevin i
go oh man i cringe that was so stupid
that was so silly but everything happens
for a reason and one of the great things
one one of the reasons i'm here it's
just all those things that have happened
and i think i've done a good job of
learning from my lessons and then
applying them in the future and so
like sinatra says no regrets
you